one of the most exclusive cars on the
market today can go from zero to 60 in
less than two and a half seconds the
bugatti
Sheerin can reach speeds up to 261 miles
an hour it is said to be the fastest
production car in the world only 500
models were built worldwide and half
have reportedly already been sold Kris
Van Cleave took a ride in this luxurious
sports car he reports from a showroom in
Connecticut and what you'll need to get
one of your own good morning it's gonna
cost you to get behind the wheel of the
new Bugatti it's the most expensive
production vehicle made and if you think
it looks good sitting here in the
showroom wait till you see it on the
roads the new Bugatti Chiron is designed
to get your attention but you'd better
look fast accelerate and I'll hit the
brakes pretty hard at the top okay
[Music]
Wow like a fighter jet we pulled nearly
2 G's hitting 116 miles per hour in just
a few seconds but that need for speed
doesn't come cheap you'll need to be in
the Tom Cruise or Jamie Foxx tax bracket
to afford one what am I gonna spend if I
want a Bugatti I would say the average
is three point three three point three
point three million dollars three point
three million dollars rate Super Lotto
is the car makers chief operating
officer you get one of five hundred cars
built worldwide and exclusive the
limited edition you get a car which is
the most powerful most beautiful and
most luxurious car in the world
our customers they win an average of 30
35 cars and they want to make it like
really the pinnacle of the collection
relaunched in the late 90s by Volkswagen
the bugatti name traces its history to
ettore bugatti who over a century ago
built cars under the motto that no car
could be too beautiful or too expensive
today Bugattis are individually built by
hand in France where nearly every detail
from the specially designed carbon fiber
skin to the color of the hand-sewn
stitching in the leather seats can all
be customized the 1500 horsepower 16
cylinder engine is the fastest in the
world Bugatti engineers had to cap the
top speed at 261 miles an hour for
safety reasons how fast could it go if
you didn't have to limit the speed
anything that we don't know yet how's
the gas mileage did you know it it's a
very good question no we don't consider
that no no customers ask about that but
the car does come with four years free
maintenance so there's that of course
for the same three million you could buy
about nine average American homes give
13 kids in Ivy League education or buy a
rolls-royce phantom for each day of the
week but a Harvard degree can't do this
under two and a half seconds per 0 to 60
that's fast butch leitzinger is Bugattis
official driver yes that's a real job
this is the moon shot from the beginning
this car was meant to be no compromises
well bugatti did make one compromise Wow
they let me drive it that's just asking
very little throttle right I was being
conservative because it's not my 3
million dollar car
the Sheeran feels like luxury and
performs like a missile and like most
people on the planet I'll never be able
to afford one to get one of these you're
gonna need to be patient there's at
least a three three-and-a-half year
waiting list but you'll be one of only
140 or so in the u.s. to own one what
you don't get for 3 million dollars is a
whole lot of trunk space
Nordia needed in that case Chris thank
you what a beautiful vehicle but way out
of a lot of people's price range yeah
most people's price range men and women
can keep on dreaming different three
million dollar price tag
let's go absolutely I don't know of any
any roads in Connecticut that have a
speed limit of 150 miles an hour so yes
for some forgiveness on the thinking of
those we did it yeah